HOW R/UNEXPECTED
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
MUCH LIKE THAT REACTION.
THE SUPER BOWL IS NOT THE ONLY
BIG THING GOING ON THIS WEEKEND,
YOU GUYS.
I'M TALKING, OF COURSE, ABOUT
WHAT-- "THE GIFFY AWARDS."
RIGHT, HONORING THE BEST
INTERNET GIFS.
TO CELEBRATE THE BIG DAY, I AM
GOING TO SHOW YOU GUYS SOME GIFS
FROM THE SUBREDDIT
R/UNEXPECTED-- WHICH IS
DELIGHTFUL AND YOU CAN GO TO IT.
THAT'S WHERE GIFS START IN ONE
WAY BUT GO IN A WAY THAT IS
UNEXPECTED, THEREFORE
JUSTIFYING THE TITLE
OF THE SUBREDDIT.
COMEDIANS, I AM GOING TO GIVE
YOU TWO OPTIONS, AND FOR 250
POINTS YOU TELL ME WHICH IS
THE ACTUAL UNEXPECTED RESULT.
HERE WE GO.
HERE WE GOT THE DALI LAMA
TRYING ON SUNGLASSES.
HE'S GOT TO PROTECT HIS EYES SO
HE CAN SEE ALL.
WILL HE START SHAKING HIS HEAD
AND PANTOMIME THE PIANO?
OR REMOVE THE GLASSES
AND SHOOT LASERS OUT
OF HIS EYES?
MYQ KAPLAN.
>> I GUESS HE IS GOING TO SHOOT
LASERS OUT OF HIS EYES.
>> Chris: YES.
SHOOTING LASERS OUT OF HIS EYES.
>> WHOA!
(LAUGHTER)
>> OH, WOW!
NICE.
>> Chris: THIS LITTLE KID ON A
SKATEBOARD.
WILL THIS LITTLE FELLA STAND UP
AND PERFECTLY PERFORM A 360
KICKFLIP OR NEVER GET UP
AND HARMLESSLY MISS
THE NEXT RAMP ENTIRELY?
YES, JAMIE LEE?
>> NEVER GET UP AND HARMLESSLY
MISS THE NEXT RAMP ENTIRELY.
>> Chris: I LIKE THE WAY YOU
THINK.
THAT IS THE CORRECT ANSWER.
LET US SEE HOW THAT PLAYS OUT.
(LAUGHTER)
THERE HE GOES.
>> THAT'S LIKE THE COOLEST WAY
TO RUN AWAY FROM HOME.
>> Chris: AND THEY NEVER SAW HIM
AGAIN!
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THIS ANIME
CHARACTER?
WILL SHE REVEAL THAT HER
NETHER-REGIONS ARE ACTUALLY
SHREK?
JUST PICTURE THAT FOR A SECOND.
OR RIDE A UNICORN
INTO THE SUN, CAUSING
THE UNICORN APOCALYPSE?
YES, STEVE AGEE?
>> SHREK PARTS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: SHOW ME SHREK (BLEEP)!
YAY!
>> NICE.
>> HE LOOKS SO SAFE.
>> Chris: PLEASE DON'T GET THAT
NEAR ME.
>> THAT (BLEEP) IS SHREKED!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: I'LL GIVE HIM POINTS
FOR THAT.
ALL RIGHT, THIS NEXT ONE, THE
MIGHTY MORPHIN POWER RANGERS.
WILL THEY: REVEAL THEMSELVES
TO BE SECRET NAZI'S OR
EACH EXPLODE INTO DIFFERENT
KINDS OF DRAGONS?
MYQ KAPLAN.
>> PLEASE NAZIS.
>> Chris: YES!
YOU ARE ABOUT TO BE REWARDED,
MYQ KAPLAN.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> ALSO I HAVE NEVER SAID,
"PLEASE NAZIS" BEFORE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> I LIKE HOW THEY'RE ALL
HAILING BUT THE PINK ONE'S LIKE
"HEY, KAREN!"
>> Chris: "HEY, HITLER!"
>> "HEY, GIRL, HEY!"
"GOOD TO SEE YOU, YOU LOOK
GOOD!
NICE 'STACHE."